[music]
>> So, when
you want to use music, there are two
options. Either handheld
or
a microphone which has a holder here
that comes in front of your
just close to your mouth, not in front
of your mouth, close to your mouth.
And then they have a skin color, so it's
seen least.
But yet, it can be seen.
The difference between the two ways is
that you can move and you can do more
actions, I agree.
My body language is there, but I cannot
There you can move.
And you can bend down.
That's what the Christian missionaries
do.
Christian missionary, they have a
handheld microphone. Now, handheld
microphone, when you move, it restricts
the gesture which we'll do.
That microphone gives freedom to you,
but doesn't look good.
Therefore, when you find singers,
whether it be Michael Jackson or
whatever it was there.
When they speak, they have these
microphones. Now, the impact of this
microphone is multiple times better than
that microphone. The modulation I can do
on this microphone is multiple times
better than a lapel microphone.
So, you have to compromise on that. The
best is have a handheld microphone. So,
most of the singers, they have handheld
microphone unless
they want to do a dance show along with
it.
I'm not telling you to watch the
singers.
But, when the singers if they really
want to have the best impact in singing,
they use these microphones which you are
having now.
The microphone you have, it's a
professional microphone, expensive one.
What are the difference? I'll tell you
when you do public address system.
The impact of modulation is multiple
times more here than on that. That has
got modulation. The advantage in that is
it gives you freedom, you can move with
both your hands. In this, your one hand
is restricted.
The advantage in that microphone is that
you can keep on walking and you can do
some actions. The gestures can be done
more.
But, I believe most of the other
gestures, that are Muslim speakers use
that and they only walk.
So, if you're only going to walk,
no difference at all. Better this.
If you want to use that, then you should
know the technique.
Then I pray.
I cannot speak when I leave the
microphone.
I'll do the action.
So, while doing action then they speak,
I have not seen any Islamic speaker
doing that. And will it look good? No.
It may get you some points.
May get you some points.
The Christian missionaries do that. How
they bend down? Book of the dancing is
fine.
Even in the Toastmasters, you see,
they come and do these actions.
Those who are not experienced, what they
do? They only walk up and down.
Useless.
If you're walking up and down, better
stay in one place and do the gestures.
So, only way you can really do is when
you can do other actions which I cannot
do now. And that is
bending.
I cannot bend and speak though people
were doing which we'll come to it later
on.
Kneeling down.
Doing some actions which I feel it's not
haram.
Kneeling down, not haram.
You're not bowing to anyone.
Putting your hand on top, not haram.
But I personally feel it doesn't give
the dignity
to an Islamic speaker to do these
things, which will not be a problem for
a non-Islamic speaker to do.
By any way, I'm not criticizing those
Muslim speakers who speak with those
microphones. By no way they're doing
haram. I personally feel this is more
effective.
If someone can use that better and wants
to do it, he's most welcome.
I would not like my students to do it
because that's a different training. Not
that I cannot do it,
but I feel
standing in one place gives
more seriousness. Imagine if I'm walking
and I quote chapter number two, chapter
number three, chapter
I can do it.
But the impact of standing here and
going like a bullet train tak tak tak
tak tak.
There is a bigger weight. So, if you use
all my techniques and all that technique
and match it, lock, stock, barrel.
Lock, stock, barrel.
Imagine if I have to walk,
I have to concentrate on that.
Now doing walking and kneeling down and
then
while I'm concentrating on my acting and
then I'm concentrating on the reference
number, chapter number one, chapter
number two, chapter number three.
Will my kneeling down give authenticity
to my talk?
Huh?
Yes, it will give a good act. I have
studied
a variety of public speakers.
And I'm aware of the pros and cons I
personally feel.
Again, let me tell you very clearly, all
these notes are 100% from my experience.
I have not copied from anywhere except
certain terminologies as I mentioned to
you two days back.
I did not attend a course.
And I disagreed with
many things they said, not all.
Many.
Now, please note when I say many,
it can be
Many means many. Many can be 10.
Correct? 10 can be 15. Out of 1,000 also
10 can be many. Percentage wise it is
one.
So, many can be 1%, 2%, 5%, 10%, 20%,
30%, 40%, 50%, 99%. Correct?
If I say nine is many, total things are
10.
So, when I use many, I'm careful when I
use many and when I use most. When I use
most, it has to be
more than 50%.
When I use
less,
again,
less can be more than 50%.
Six, only six. Less out of 10.
So, when I say majority, it is more than
50%. When I say most and majority, more
than 50%. Now, when I say most or
majority, it's anywhere between more
than 50 and less than 100%.
When I say almost all,
it means above 90%.
There's no percentage for almost all.
When I say few,
few can be two, three, four, five, six.
Few and many can be same.
One time when I use few,
it means 10.
Few people in Bombay.
15 people out of 25 million. Is it few
or not?
Many people here have done their
homework.
15 people with many.
10 also is many.
So, depending upon the whole,
therefore, when you use in your lecture,
you have to be careful here. Many times
I hear Muslims say,
"All did like that." Every time every
time.
And I'm very specific. Every time all.
When I ask how many hours you say all.
Don't tell me this.
How many means our number. So, when I
attended this training program, many
points I differ with.
These notes I have not
picked up from anywhere. It's mainly by
personal experience.
All these notes.
Almost all.
Some points I have
point form
terminus, gestures,
the words.
So, this is by my experience
and
Yes, for example, research is done that
I went to the research and I
found the research.
So, that's the reason
this is a personal opinion. People may
differ.
Don't come and tell me, "Okay, I went to
that expert." Fine, he's an expert. I'm
Doctors differ.
So, when you go to super specialty, the
more super specialty you go to, more
chances of differing.
If you go to general,
chances of differing is less.
The more super specialty you do,
difference of opinion will increase.
So, then you have to choose
who is more effective. Who's telling
you? Then you see the credentials.
This is mainly by experience.
So, all these things are mainly by
experience.
And I will show you also.
I will show clipping of the person who
came out first in Toastmasters.
The person who came out second.
Good effective.
But then you compare him with
who you think can get crowds.
And if you use the structure and content
to that, some will work, some will not
work.
If you use all the things that we have
mentioned here, it's difficult to
implement the other things what we are
going to do in that type of speech. So,
let a small loss take place to prevent a
big loss is the ruling of the Sharia.
So, I do agree that it's effective in
terms of people's attention.
But, there are drawbacks also to it.
Any other questions? Okay, brother Sabu.
You better go ahead or that we get stuck
here.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullah. Wa
alaykumu s-salam warahmatullah
wabarakatuh.
As you said and also mentioned here,
sir, about giving advice on
giving
talks without note
is good.
So, what is your opinion about giving
talks with modern technologies,
which most of the people now consider it
as the modern way of giving talks
in gathering. As-salamu alaykum.
As far as giving talks with modern
technology, there is a separate session
that we'll be having.
Inshallah, maybe after about
3 4 days.
But, you haven't heard everything.
So, see, the moment I answer, I'll have
to tell you something of the structure.
So, this question, after we finish the
techniques and structure and content,
you can ask. Okay?
Therefore, I told you don't ask
questions which are going to come. If
you have read, there is something as
ancillary aids
for public speaking.
Ancillary aids.
If you take out the 45-days
schedule,
ancillary aids is what we'll be talking
and that time we'll talk, inshallah.
Is that clear?
But,
>> [music]
>> arju ridaka Allah.
And the rain will yeah.
Have me a hot guy yeah.
And tell Karim
I'm in Carolina yeah.
And tell him
yeah.
Because I got you yeah.
And tell him
>> [music]
[music]
>> I don't like men who stare.
I'm a little monkey love
I have a
little man who
I love